armed guards and heightened security
checks didn't deter the thousands of
people who travel to be here many came
to see a man who despite having left
public office more than four months ago
was still treated to a rockstars welcome
in that time Barack Obama's high regard
for the German Chancellor hasn't changed
first of all a good thought it's good to
see all of you back at Berlin I have to
say first of all that not only do I love
this city but one of my favorite
partners throughout my presidency is
sitting next to me today Chancellor
Merkel has done outstanding work not
just here in Germany but around the
world small talk soon gave way to
serious reflection tight security wasn't
the only shadow the Manchester bombing
cast over this gathering
that's awesome cotton cake Fortson you
thought the deterrent strategy that
worked in the Cold War had its dark side
but it prevented numerous conflicts from
escalating not least because both sides
were attached to life itself that's not
true
of terrorist groups they're ready to
sacrifice their own lives to destroy
those of others as we saw in Manchester
terrorism and war also preoccupied the
people invited to pose questions once
again why did a Christian and Nobel
Prize laureate repeatedly authorized
drone attacks despite civilian
casualties
Obama gave a frank response in some
cases
you know we I know for a fact that
actions that I took might have resulted
in civilian casualties oftentimes as a
consequence of error defending new
restrictions on immigration Merkel said
Germany must resort to deportation when
needed
Divac that's a dilemma we have to bear
we have to make the right choices about
who must go and on the question of
fairness all I can say is we have to
make those choices quickly such words
from the former president and the most
powerful woman in Europe resonated with
listeners the vaquita
it's important to convey the sense that
politics just doesn't take place far
away from the public it's actually a
dialogue between citizens and in
response to their concerns I thought it
was good that he said war should always
be only the last resort and that each of
us can do our bit to make the world a
better place be safe it's about and
cotton and that indeed was the message
here that everyone can be a part of hope
and change